Speaker 1: Well, per a number of reports,
including ones we looked at earlier, Donald Trump
is getting ready to announce his 2024 Republican
primary presidential candidacy. A number of
reasons why he is looking to do it. It seems
pretty clear now. It does seem as though
his mood is not quite right. Donald Trump
spent the better part of Sunday afternoon,
absolutely losing it on truth social his social
media platform whose name even he gets wrong
sometimes. He delivered a 14 post screed all
within a short period of time Sunday afternoon,
and something seems to be very, very wrong. Donald
Trump starting by posting a bright article about
how Mike Lee is leading. Evan McMullin
I believe his name is actually McMullin,
but you know, who cares, right? In Utah's
Senate, the Utah Senate's general election race,
Trump likes Mike Lee. Mike Lee is a Trumpist.
Then Trump posts an article from the Federalist
saying that courts have ruled states didn't
follow their own election laws in 2020.
This is a very popular claim, part of the dozen
or two dozen. However, you know, different claims
that are being made by Trump Republicans about
the 2020 election that states didn't follow
their own laws. Now, as we've covered before and
covered pretty extensively, what they mean by that
is that in some states, rules about elections
were changed without going through the
legislature. That's different than states didn't
follow their own laws. What it means is that
other reasons, in particular the pandemic, were
used to say, actually, we're going to let whoever
wants to vote absentee, vote absentee. Of course,
they have to go through the process, have to be
registered to vote, have to be citizens, all
have to be alive, all these different things.
And it's just a talking point. The states didn't
states broke their own laws. No, they're just
the rules for how to run an election were
modified in ways consistent with the law.
Trump then posting an article from Townhall.com.
Trump was right there sending their rapists. Now,
this is, of course, related to the story
of the ten year old girl who was tragically
raped and impregnated in Ohio. And due to Ohio's
abortion law, had to leave Ohio, go to Indiana
to obtain an abortion. This is now, as I said last
week. The the thing they're going to focus on at
first, they said the story was was made up. Kristi
Noem, Jim Jordan, it's a long list of different
people who said the story is just fake. There
is no ten year old girl. Or if there is, she was
raped or she was raped, she wasn't impregnated.
If she was impregnated, she didn't really need
to go to Indiana. Well, it all happened. It
then was learned that the believed perpetrator
is allegedly undocumented. Now they care
about the story, but not about the part
that we've been talking about. So Trump then goes
to that. Then Trump posts an article from HANNITY
Worst President Ever after the inflation report.
Worst President Trends on Twitter. Now, of course,
as I'm sure you know by now, inflation has nothing
to do with Joe Biden. Inflation is happening
globally. It's much higher than in the U.S. In
some countries, it's much lower than in the US.
In some countries, it doesn't have anything to
do with Biden. Trump's just rapid fire posting
this stuff. Okay. Next, Trump posts the picture of
the alleged rapist in the ten year old Ohio story,
of course, saying that there is a cover up of
the fact that he's believed to be an illegal
immigrant. There is no such cover up. I reported
it to you within the first minute of telling
you the story. The real cover up is they are
covering up the fact that they called the story
fake for a week until they could no longer
deny it and none of them apologized for it.
Trump tweeting about that, tweeting, sorry,
true thing about that. Trump then posting
an oversize image related to inflation and
the changes to inflation, which of course
have nothing to do with Joe Biden. So Trump
jumping on that one, just rapid fire. Desperate,
desperate Trump. Trump then posting an article
from Yahoo News called Daily. This is John Daly,
a pro-Trump golfer. Daly calls for British
Open return to Daddy Trump's Turnberry.
The British Open was taken out of Trump's golf
course. John Daly likes Trump and Trump signal
boosting that. What is Trump doing that he has so
much time? Trump then posting an article from Just
the news, not a particularly trustworthy
website. Bombshells Undercut the Big Lie
21 Confirmed Illegalities and irregularities
from 2020 folks. 150 million votes.
150 million votes they have now found. Think about
this. They have now found after nearly two years,
21. Instances of wrongdoing. 21. 150 million
people voted. Trump wants us to see it and say,
Wow, I guess he was right. Then Trump with a
bright BART article exclusive. Trump endorsed
Senate candidate Markwayne Mullin. The red wave is
real and it's coming. Meaningless article. The red
wave may be coming, but all polling is showing a
dramatic shift away from Republicans and towards
Democrats thanks to what happened with Roe v Wade.
Thanks to what has not happened on gun safety,
which is nothing has happened. Trump then posting
a graph he probably doesn't even understand.
Exclusive Blake Masters Trump endorsement has been
like rocket fuel for this campaign. Maybe. I mean,
okay, let's wait and see what happens there.
Trump then posting from the insanely dangerous
and weaponized conspiracy website, The Gateway
Pundit. Trump appointed judge blocks Air Force
from expelling unvaccinated service members and
enforcing vaccine mandate. Just anti-vaxx pablum
that we've seen from Trump. Trump then with an
article from right side broadcasting another
extreme right wing media outlet, victim
Michaels will win if he remains strong
on the rigged and stolen election, Trump says.
Otherwise, he has no chance. Increasingly untrue,
actually talking about the rigged in stone. A
stolen election seems to pull worse and worse,
even with Republican voters. And then Donald
Trump posting a video of Mark Levin from Fox
News claiming that the January 6th committee is
a setup to, quote, kill the Republican Party.
Trump then posting a video of Sean HANNITY talking
to Laura Ingraham on Fox News and then Donald
Trump saying the UN Select Committee and the fake
news media refuse to go anywhere near these two
topics, especially the rigged election where the
evidence of fraud is incontestable. This is a
former president, folks. Just, just posting,
posting, posting. Then Trump posting memes
one about how people had more savings under Trump.
And of course, the reason for that is everything
was closed and everything being closed and
people just sitting at home due to the pandemic
increased the savings rate. Many countries saw
that had nothing to do with Trump. And by the way,
the funniest part about bragging about
the larger savings rate under Trump
is a high savings rate is not considered
particularly good for the economy. And what
I mean by that is when you save money in a savings
account, you're not injecting it into the economy.
It's under traditional economic thinking which
people like Trump claim to believe in and support.
You don't want people saving. You want
people spending. This is something they
talk about all the time. And then also Donald
Trump congratulating Kim Smith on winning the
open championship at St Andrews. Nobody
really cares about that. A 14 post screed.
And Trump is reportedly panicked about forthcoming
criminal charges and believed to be announcing his
2024 run very soon. I have to tell you, part
of me wonders and thinks might be interesting
to let him back on Twitter. What would he
even do if he was allowed back on Twitter?